let's move over to the big story
yesterday which was cnn president jeff
zucker who has almost single-handedly
destroyed cnn people think oh it's
jeffrey tubin masturbating that's
destroying cnn it's chris cuomo and his
brother with the big q-tip destroying
cnn it's don lemon pretending to be a
journalist destroying cnn well
somebody's in charge of all of these
people and that's the guy by the name of
jeff zucker who's been a tv executive
for decades already he was pretty well
respected in the industry but he has
single-handedly just demolished cnn the
ratings were absolutely terrible
everything else well yesterday out of
nowhere while we were live on air right
here uh he stepped down we've got some
info from the associated press cnn
president jeff zucker abruptly resigned
wednesday after acknowledging a
consensual relationship with another
network executive an entanglement that
came to light during an investigation of
now fired anchor chris cuomo i
acknowledge the relationship had evolved
in recent years zucker wrote in a memo
announcing the end of his nine-year
tenure i was required to disclose it
when it began but i didn't i was wrong
in a statement zucker said he wished
that his tenure at cnn had ended
differently but it was an amazing run
and i loved every minute so let's just
do the last part first i mean by amazing
run i mean he destroyed cnn cnn is a
punch line it's a joke the reason that
mainstream media goes after joe rogan
every day is because joe rogan is bigger
than cnn no matter how big brian
stelter's head is or how big he says
their newsroom is as we covered
yesterday uh he he destroyed the place i
don't care about the specifics of of
what he did and if he's in love with
this woman like she loves him it's like
good for you guys like that's just fine
uh if it's a company policy he broke so
be it the bigger issue here is that as
we talk about on this show every day the
the mainstream ability the corporate
press ability to keep any of us feeling
like they're telling us the truth has
been completely destroyed by people like
jeff zucker i mean his tenure at cnn was
a disaster
so
even though it's kind of good let's say
for a guy like me right like i just tell
you what i think you can agree or not
agree you can watch or not watch you can
share a video or not watch but because
they're so bad it does drive people to
us right so on one hand it's like all
right let them keep crumbling but i
truly mean this it would be much better
for the country as a whole
and i don't believe i'm not like one of
these polyanisha people that believes
that you can just magically make
everybody come together and have these
kumbaya moments especially anymore maybe
there were ways to do it before the
internet or maybe 10 or 15 years ago
something like that i don't think you
can do it anymore but would it be better
if when people turned on what was the
most trusted name in news that it was
trusted would it be better when people
opened up the new york times that was
once all the news that's fit to print
was actually all the news that's fit to
print and not all the news that's fit to
make up or
you know turn into propaganda or
whatever it might be or leak stories
from the democratic administration and
leak stories about a republican
administration you guys get all that
like of course that would be better so
if you're somebody that's going to maybe
take the interim job at cnn i wish you
luck i really do i really really do and
i hope you put on a freaking kick-ass
show at 11 a.m eastern right up against
the ruin report that is so good that
people stop watching this show
but i don't think it's gonna happen uh
and to all of that point uh there's
something else interesting going on in
the cable news situation related to
tucker carlson
and i thought this was really really
maybe indicative of what what is bigger
uh than just jeff zucker stepping down
because of the because of this
relationship this might really be the
reason he's stepping down uh we've got
some info from the rap in october tucker
carlson's 9 pm eastern program was the
top cable news show among democrats in
the advertiser coveted age range of 25
to 54. fox news also commanded the
largest number of independents in the
key news demo during prime time and
total day hours 55 of those 25 to 54
watch the network in prime time compared
to cnn's 23
and msnbc's 22
during total day hours 58 of
independents in the demo watch fox news
18 chose msnbc and 25 selected cnn more
surprising are the stats about carlson
and fox news's poll with self-proclaimed
democrats of those demo-aged viewers
surveyed who identified as democrats 39
chose fox news 31 chose msnbc and 30
chose cnn for programming from 8 to 11
pm eastern in total day viewership fox
news grabbed 42 percent of democrats
aged 25 to 54 cnn nab 33 and msnbc got
25. so look the key part here without
getting lost
in ratings or how actually legit they
are or how many people are walking by
things at bars or at you know uh
airports wherever it might be the key
thing here is that tucker is crushing it
with relatively young democrats
do you see the shift that is taking
place
do you guys see it like there is
something massive taking place and when
you add all of these stories up
the people that lie losing audience the
people that are telling the truth or
selling telling something approximate to
the truth or talking about what peop
real people care about that their
numbers are blowing up whether it's
tucker or rogan or whatever it might be
it's like there's a move happening you
throw in the trucker thing and you see
people standing up something good is
happening
or i'm just drinking a lot of coffee i'm
not sure but i think it's probably both
actually to be quite frank